uh
hi everyone welcome to our homeroom live
stream
sal khan here from khan academy i'm very
excited about
the very relevant guest we have today
randy weingarten president of the
american federation of teachers
before we jump into that conversation i
encourage you to start thinking of your
questions put them in the message boards
on
facebook and youtube but i will give my
standard announcement a reminder to
folks that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization
we can only exist through philanthropic
donations so if you're in a position to
do so please think about going to khan
academy.org
donate i also want to give a special
shout out to several organizations that
have stepped up
over the last several weeks actually
months when
kovit picked up they realized that khan
academy was already running at a deficit
pre-kovid
and then as you could imagine the
traffic to our site we've wanted to
accelerate a whole series of programs
for families and teachers
uh so our deficit has only increased uh
but these organizations really stepped
up
and and helped close some of that
special thanks to bank of america
google.org att fastly novartis and
actually the amgen foundation
and many of the other supporters both
organizations foundations corporations
and individuals
who make all of this possible so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating
so with that i am honored uh to invite
our guest
to introduce our guest randy weingarten
president
of the american federation of teachers
uh thank you so much for joining us
randy
thank you i'm honored to be with you and
really honored that the whatever
tropical storm hurricane we're going
through
seems like it is passing through quickly
so people will appreciate it
that's that's that's the honor well
it's i guess it's better to go fast than
than to go slow exactly
i grew up in new orleans having all of
this
right i really admire your work and i'm
really
i'm i'm really i was really excited to
have this conversation
so thank you no no likewise and clearly
uh
the hurricane is is only one thing
that's going on in everyone's lives
right now
as you just mentioned covid and
obviously something that you've been
very central in is a conversation around
how schools should could reopen and what
are the supports we need
so so maybe a good place to start you
know i just love to know where your
head is you know what are you doing on a
day-to-day basis
uh and and how are you thinking about
the school
uh opening situation so
thank you for asking the question that
way so i mean my
my head is kind of
bursting all the time right now because
this would be hard regardless
if you had good leadership in the
country this would be hard
with leadership that is incompetent
and still denying
covet exists it makes it
almost impossible to try to figure out
how to get people
the right information the science-based
information
and how to keep communities safe and so
i find it very frustrating i want to
scream most of the time
and i don't because it's really
important
to be heard right now and it's important
to make sure that
that that people hear what is accurate
information
even if they don't want to believe it so
we started thinking
about how to reopen school safely
in the beginning of april because we
didn't want to have
what happened in march happen again the
haphazard way that schools were
closed our view was we were going to
learn as much as we possibly could
from as many of the
world-renowned epidemiologists
virologists
infectious disease folks as we could and
we had the advantage that we are the
second largest nurse union
not simply the second largest largest
teachers union
so in april we put out a
very we put out our first plan about how
do we open schools and communities
safely
and we spent a lot of time talking to
people before we did that
including our own members including
parents and including all
the all the scientists i just talked
about we just put out another one an
updated one about a week or two ago but
frankly
even though we know a lot more about
the virus the safeguards
are basically the same you have to
contain the virus in a region
you have to maintain that containment by
testing tracing and isolation
you have to have the school
safeguards that would prevent a virus
from spreading in the school
which includes six feet of physical
distancing
and mass cleaning and ventilation and
that's a top
of reasonably accommodating those who
are high risk
and obviously washing our hands and you
have to actually have a way to pay for
that
and that's just on the safety side on
the
on the well-being and the instructional
side
we need to have a lot better way of
making sure remote instruction can
engage kids
in some ways like you have done so
successfully
and we also need to really focus on
well-being issues on digital divide
issues
and food and nutrition issues so we've
been trying to do
all of those things at the same time in
3 500 locations
no it's a it's not an enviable task and
you know i speak to a lot of district
superintendents and
and administrators and teachers and
everyone is in this really really
difficult situation right now
i know and we'll get into a little bit
of some of the contentious points about
should a school be open or closed and
distance learning good bad etc
but have you seen pockets of of people
doing it well
uh either at the district level or the
state level
yes they're very very quiet about it
because they don't want people to follow
them
and they don't want because because
anyone who's doing it well
knows that at any moment there could be
a kid or a teacher that
tests positive for covid and then you
have to close down immediately and you
have to
actually go through all the safety
protocols and then
you pray that you know that people don't
get sick
you know and or don't get very very sick
so
a lot of the places you know like like
for example newark
um had summer school i i
frankly pushed for places to do
some summer schooling if they could
first and foremost because of the kids
who really needed it who who you know
didn't connect well on you know on on
the screens like you and i are
having right now but also to do it in a
very safe way
and in a way where we could learn things
and so
you know in places like detroit it
didn't work very well
but a place like newark it worked um
pretty well or a place like boces
in suffolk county it worked pretty well
montana it worked pretty well
now to me what do i mean when i say it
worked pretty well
it means one there were no negative
cases
there were no positive cases of covid
and kids
came teachers were there there were the
safety measures in place
that is you know wonderful
but it's also lucky when i say newark
worked very well
it's because there were a couple of
positive cases and they
handled it well and they closed the
school that communicated with
with parents and with with teachers they
made sure that people got tests
immediately
and they made sure they did everything
that they could to keep kids
and to keep their keep educators safe
and then before they reopened
they did all the kind of protocols
including cleaning
and everything and and contract contact
tracing
to make sure that um that everybody who
was in contact
with the person who tested positive um
they had gotten in contact with and
those people were isolating
so so that's the kind of thing that you
have to do
if you have like what is happening when
it
county in in in georgia you see 240
people testing positive
in the first few days that is a big
problem that is an
sos that means you've got to have a
different structure that's not
close a school close a pod see what
happens that means you've got too much
community spread in that community
and you need to be on remote instruction
because school should not be open in
that situation
so so we're you know we're seeing
with both summer school as well as
the starting of the school year places
that are doing it well in places they're
doing it badly
but we also don't have the resources
from washington yet which we need very
badly
and we also have a president who is
being
who who who is breeding chaos instead of
responsibility
this is the moment that you need to be
really responsible
not chaotic and his and his recklessness
is actually hurting things i'll i'll
give you one example
in june we polled our members
and remember this is before you saw this
huge escalation in the south and
southwest
and 75 of them said that if we could get
the safety
safeguards that we were advocating for
they were comfortable
with going back to school buildings
because they knew
how important it was and it is for kids
not just for feeding and not just for
well-being but for instruction as well
and so that if i polled my members right
now
you'd see the exact reverse
and you see the reverse because they
don't have confidence that
that some of the precautions that you
mentioned in a newark place like a new
york context
that those are in place that's where the
fear is
i would say you'd see it for four
reasons one
because of the huge
increase in spread in the south and
southwest
you know even though this week you seem
to have we have 14 states that are hot
spots rather than 18 states
you still have 40 states you where you
see
the line going like this as opposed to
going like this
that is not and and and and and
and that's number one number two you
have a president who is a denier
so yesterday he got on tv and said
everything is going well
even though dr burks the day before said
that
um that things are really not my words
not her words
her words were things um were
really um spreading very extensively
so number two is the president's
recklessness number three
is that there's been a lack of resources
from washington
so number four the planning that's been
done
is still in many many places very very
vague
because they've they planned hybrid
but there's not a whole lot of
meat behind you know that's there's not
a lot of muscle behind that planning
if i'm understanding it correctly i mean
it makes a lot of sense i'm just trying
to think through it logically
if you're in a part of the country that
has low
community spread it can have some spread
but low community spread but it seems
like it's in control
then open up in a very careful way have
your contact tracing have the social
distancing have the ventilation
and keep track and as soon as the
contact tracing
traces contacts within a school you do
have to shut down which
makes all the sense in the world and in
places where you have high community
spread
there's no point in trying to be
physical because you're very quickly
going to trigger a situation
and you're going to just exacerbate the
scenario so that to me feels like
a very reasonable i mean logical i don't
you know
somehow this is it does feel like it's
gotten politicized when you look at the
media it seems like there's these kind
of polar camps one is you know kind of
open schools no matter what and one is
don't open schools no matter what and i
don't i'm definitely not hearing that
from you
no and it's different look oh we we have
50 states we have 98 000 schools we have
16 000 school districts
we've never had a one size fits all for
schooling
ever on virtually anything so why would
you do it on the most complicated things
that that have affected america in
probably a hundred years
we haven't had a pandemic like this in a
hundred years so
so that's why i'm saying but i think
that the reason we have this polar
opposite
is because and and i'm you know i'm
sorry that i'm blaming the political
leadership so much
but they deserve to be blamed i don't
believe
we would have i don't believe this is a
republican or democratic issue
i do not believe margaret spellings
would have
had been um like betsy devos
if she was the secretary of education
right now i know arne duncan wouldn't be
he's been on tv a lot and said this is
crazy
we would have the what would have
happened
um with any normal republican
um government or democratic government
would be
what happened in europe which is here's
an emergency
you bring stakeholders together you know
district superintendents
chief school officers principals
teachers
parent groups pta and
you bring them together under the
auspices of the secretary of education
way back in april and you come up with
guideposts
about how to do remote learning just
like
you have done so well just like we did
with capstone projects and we have done
with our platform share my lesson but
you
socialize this and i don't mean it
politically you
you socialize it you broaden it you
communicate it through the country
and you do it through the department of
education as guidance
and then you do the same exact thing in
april and may and june
in terms of the preparing for the next
year so that
districts had some guidance about what
to do
instead we're still having this bizarre
conversation about whether or not
covet is dangerous yes covid is
dangerous
yes it's killed over 156 000 people
yes we have for one we have over four
million cases right now
this is a pandemic the fact that the
president and the secretary of education
don't actually say that over and over
again is completely unconscionable
thank god younger children don't are
more resilient than everyone else
and thank god they don't seem to get
as sick as others and thank god we've
had
enough therapeutics and other things so
that people who are testing positive
who are getting sick right now who are
on ventilators right now
many of them get well but the fact that
there
is that there's any dispute about
whether or not this virus is dangerous
that is part of the lack of credibility
and the lack of trust
that's making our work much harder
because of the polarization
no i i mean this is incredibly difficult
for for for
i could imagine a couple of questions i
definitely want to get to the
instructional side of things and and how
can teachers and families navigate as
there's a ton of questions that are
coming in
through social media but just to stay on
this kind of the logistics question
and and also to kind of understand how
this might play out
you know i've also heard alternative
solutions you touched on this notion
that potentially you're five six seven
maybe eight-year-olds don't necessarily
spread the virus or spread it as
much um are there hybrid cases where we
bring
those kids back you know in the
tuberculosis tuberculosis epidemic uh
almost 100 years ago people did things
like outdoor schooling
is are are types are things like that on
the table and then
the second part of my question they
should be
but what's happened is this political
reality that many mayors face that
schools have been used as child care
and instead of actually having
side-by-side child
care that's absolutely essential as well
right now
and where you know people could do kids
could have done remote education while
they were in child care
but we need schools are not child care
schools or schools and so part of this
is that schools are used in normal times
for many purposes yes they are central
community
yes they are about you know empowering
kids
yes they need to be equitable yes we
need to make them excellent for all
but you know they are basically used
you know in in they are relied on for so
many communal purposes
and that's part of the problem right now
so i do
think if we looked at the research today
what we would be doing
is what israel did in terms of its
second take at it which is you would
open
first off you have to have professional
development
which hasn't happened i i'm lifting up
the massachusetts example because i
think
them pulling together two weeks of
professional development for their
teachers
at the beginning of this year to really
think through
how to use remote how to use hybrid how
to instruct kids
because it's really different as you
know instructing kids
through a camera is very different than
instructing kids
um personally you know it's it's a
different art
it's a different engagement it's really
different and it takes different skills
and you have to do things differently so
having that
now having that kind of knowledge and
professional development is very very
important
the second piece that's important is
really trying to have professional
development
about where kids are right now because
the anxiety level is huge
particularly in communities that have
been most
affected um covid affects
people who are black and brown more than
affects people who are white it affects
people who are poor more than it affects
people who are not
and so we have to be mindful of the
objective that is and
and the anxiety the same is true in
terms of unemployment unemployment has
affected people who are black and brown
more than as effective people who are
white
and the same is true in terms of all the
reckoning that we're doing right now in
terms of racial
injustice so you have three kind of
um crises that have careened into each
other
and so the well-being issues and how we
address that with our kids are really
really
important so you have to have that
professional development but the second
piece to your question saw which is
really
important so which which is really
important sorry is that
knowing full well that younger kids
um seem to have less
or seem to have more resilience even
though they can spread more they're seen
or they even though that their studies
that say that they are
carriers they have more resilience you
can
actually start having smaller
hybrid models or smaller pods of 12
kids or so with a teacher
um and and and do it with young kids
and that seems like it's been more
successful
both in denmark now in israel and
in germany so why don't we learn from
that
and bring the younger kids in in that
kind of way
and keep the older kids either on hybrid
or
slowly have outdoor schools with group
sessions and things like that
so what you just said sounds very very
reasonable i'm actually not getting this
nuance when i read
newspaper articles when i'm i'm i'm
watching the news
is this where the conversation is are
people having this conference or
is this gotten polarized and people are
just kind of you know
we're not opening schools or we are
opening schools it's it's
it is where the conversation started to
go
in i would say in
late june i started seeing a lot
of much more robust thoughtful
conversations
but throughout july since trump did his
recklessness you have basically
you know he interjected himself in this
and you have basically the huge
polarization as a result of it
because all those you know trumpster
governors like the one in georgia and
the one in
florida and the and and arizona
are not going to do a thing that he
doesn't like
and so they instead of being
much more nuanced about what we need to
do
to actually help schools
to help open school buildings
responsibly and gradually
in a way that helps children and doesn't
endanger children and teachers you would
be doing it the way i just talked about
but if the goal is that
you have to get kids into schools in a
sardine-like way
because their parents need to go to work
or the goal is
uh you need to do this because um
you you know you want to see the
employment numbers go up
or your goal is you know just to create
a divide because you think the teachers
unions are going one way
so you want to show parents you're going
to go another way
and you're doing it politically so if
those are all your goals
you get to where you've gotten to right
now which is chaos
if your goal is how do we actually help
knowing full well we're in a pandemic
get kids back to school
safely in a way that doesn't end
endanger
kids and teachers you would be starting
with professional development
remote and slowly bring kids in
um you know you using younger kids and
special needs kids first
because there seems to be much less
transmission
for those kids and and they they
probably need the physical experience
the most to
your point especially special special
needs kids
there's so many questions i want to get
to on the on the instructional
professional development side that
you've heard but just you know one last
question on just kind of how
this is going to play out i guess you
could say logistically or politically
over the next
uh two three weeks as we get into the
the meet of back to school
you know what is your prediction i mean
it sounds like you're you are
not you're not holding your breath that
great things are going to happen in some
of the states that are going to kind of
open
and and i guess pretend that things are
normal uh but
are you seeing pockets where there's
hope i mean you mentioned massachusetts
is newark what do you think is going to
look like you know if we were to have
this conversation a month what's our
postmortem of the back to school season
so if you asked me a month ago i was
much more optimistic than i am right now
um i'm you know and and every time
the president tweets some um foolishness
i'm much less optimistic because it
creates the polarization
rather than having the conversation you
know they're useless
devos is useless there's no guidance
from her
we haven't had the resources that we
need and we know
states are still laying people off and
they have had
twenty percent budget cuts and we need
millions
and millions of dollars for um ppe and
cleaning and all of this stuff
so you know i feel um as as i'm glad
that they're negotiating
this week but we need that we need the
resources from washington
and we need trump and devos to shut
their mouths
if if that happened um
i would say that you'd see a lot of
places
starting on remote i think that
unfortunately because of the lack of
resources and because of the
covid increase you're going to see a lot
of places starting on remote education
and then you know slowly
with the professional development with
tackling the
virus you'll you'll start seeing
school districts bring in the most
at-risk kids
in a hybrid fashion um i think that this
notion
that that they were going to start with
every single child
back on the day after labor day you know
and and
that that would be you know and they
would going to be able to do that
every school district that has has
attempted to do that initially
is now um rolling back their plans
and you know part of it let me let me
just say
so part of it is what has happened in
gwinnett county
in alabama and um in georgia
and what's happened in indiana and also
what's happened in terms of summer
school summer school
places did some of this very slowly and
a couple of places did it well like
newark
and a couple of places like detroit you
know had
real outbreaks and there was real
consternation as a result of it
and when i say newark did well i mean
there were places like there's places
like
boces on eastern long island where
knockwood they had summer school
they had a very small summer school they
had summer school they didn't have a
case of covet they didn't have a
positive case
that i would say that's luck you know
because when i say newark did it well
it's because if you have a positive case
it's a matter of how you deal with it
how you create trust and how you
actually do the work you have to do
to shut down the school make sure it's
communicated that there's a positive
case
make sure you make make sure that that
you do the contract
contact tracing so that you isolate
everybody who was in
in you know contact with that person and
newark did that well
and it created you know it created some
credibility
but think about what's going on we spent
all this time talking about logistics
and how little time talking about what
we need to do in terms of instruction
whether it's hybrid or whether it's
remote
absolutely and one last question on the
logistics because the instruction is at
least as important in this world
you know obviously when you read the
headlines especially the last few weeks
this notion of potential
strikes i have at least been surfaced
if if i'm you know based on our
conversation so far i'm perceiving that
what you're saying is
uh strikes where there are not
precautions where community spread is so
high that it would be just fundamentally
unsafe
to send someone into that is is that
what y'all are
advocating how are you thinking about
that right the word in front of strike
was the word safety safety strikes and
labor
have a very particular meeting and they
are
only a last resort if you can't do
if you can't make it safe in any other
way we feel
that we are now the conscience of the
country
of making sure our kids
our communities and our educators are
safe
and the fact that others are reckless
makes us need to be more responsible
like no one got
into teaching to be a safety monitor and
and
you know i'm a social studies teacher
and a lawyer
so learning all this about learning all
the science
was hard for me to learn but you have to
learn it in the middle of a pandemic
and you have to have those guard rails
and i have to look at a lot of people
straight in the eyes
and say that in order to
advise that that a school a school
building should reopen
that the the kind of things that are
done
to prevent virus spread are in there and
if they're not
in there i in good conscience cannot
advise that a building should reopen
it doesn't mean that there's not going
to be a covet positive case
but we need to make sure that everything
we can do is done
that's what hospitals do that's what
nursing homes should have done
and we need to do that for schools as
well we know what we need to do
those and yes it's a logistical
challenge but if others
refuse to do it that's why you have
unions
that's why you have collective
bargaining that's why you have
collective goodwill
sometimes you have to take the moral
responsibility
to make sure that things are safe for
people
right it is boiled down to kind of the
most fundamental
purpose of unions which is workplace
safety uh which
and this isn't some blanket statement
that you know no school openings at all
it's only when it
is unsafe exactly and
and frankly that's why even at our
convention last week
somebody raised that motion you know we
had a virtual convention we had
resolutions
and you know there were two or three
resolutions where
people tagged on a motion that says we
will not reopen schools unless the virus
rate is zero or unless there is a
vaccine
and those motions were rejected by my
membership
we know that there is not
a zero risk situation here we know that
it's that kids
need in-school schooling teachers would
tell you that
you know pre-pandemic they would have
said we need to see our kids
we need to have smaller class sizes and
remote instruction doesn't work very
well
saw con notwithstanding that's what
people would have said
now they'll say it even more but it has
to be safe because if it's not safe
then what ends up happening is a school
outbreak
could end up reinfecting an entire
community and so places like new york
and new jersey and connecticut that went
through those sacrifices
that the businesses that didn't reopen
early
why would we put them through this again
after all the work that they have done
we have to educate our kids
but we have to make it safe no that
makes sense i mean my wife and i were
talking about she's a physician and even
she works for the county hospital
she's a rheumatologist so she's not a
you know pulmonologist she's not one of
the frontline workers here
but for for the rheumatologist there too
they're making sure that they have all
the ppe
patients that they can see remotely they
are the patients that they absolutely
have to see
uh the precautions are incredible that
they're taking with the monitoring the
temperature checks the ppe et cetera
and then you know to if if you don't if
you didn't have those my wife did not
have those precautions as a healthcare
professional
i would not encourage her to to to
to show up um if you know our
mother-in-law lives with us i mean you
know
it's just for the safety of the
community i mean going into the
instructional side
which as as we've both been alluding to
you know we've been so focused on
logistics the whole world has that
the the teacher uh training the pd days
etc you know there's a lot of questions
coming in i'll try to
give a synopsis of some of them this is
a question from a teacher on facebook
randy will remote learning make teachers
obsolete will it damage the profession
and then from facebook sarah jabin is
asking you know
what kind of student engagement through
remote learning is actually working so
so what does good distance learning look
like
even you were very kind when you said
khan academy but you know i think it's
working even khan academy in certain
places i think some places it's not
working
optimally because they're not getting
enough supports the teachers aren't
getting enough support so i'd love your
frame on you know what what should that
professional development look like for
teachers
right what does at least decent just
look at distance learning look like
so you know all kids are different
and all ages are different so again
there's not a one size fits all
in terms of distance learning but for
the teacher who raised that question
i think that this that we have now that
that the pandemic has now proven that
distance learning is a supplement
not a substitute for in-person teaching
and learning
that you know that the alchemy that
happens in a class
the engagement in person is really
really important for kids
but it can be a supplement and
ultimately right now
i see this year as a bridge year we're
in the middle of a pemdak
just like with tp just like what's the
spanish flu of a hundred years ago
just like with polio we have to take
these things seriously and then we have
to catch
we have to help kids feel confident
that they will be able to achieve
regardless and then
as these things subside or we get a
vaccine or we get therapeutics
like in aids we don't have a vaccine and
aids but we have therapeutics
we're able you know you can see what has
happened in terms of the
um lgbtq community in terms of
of what happened in the aftermath of a
of of having
the the therapeutics you know in the
late 80s early 90s what i think we have
to do
in terms of instruction this is what
i've seen work
and frankly it's just from talking to
people
who have done it over the course of the
last several
months number one we have to be mindful
of how much screen time people have
we also have to make sure that there's
real group instruction
a symptom asymmetric learning can
actually really work but schedules are
really really important for younger kids
and when i say a asymptomatic learning
can work
high school teachers have said to me
that they could actually tape a lesson
and then use screen time to reinforce
that lesson you know screen
you can use time you can i'm a big
believer in
getting some tense up and having some
open-air
classrooms in parks in september and
october and doing
small group instruction that way just
like some um
some uh uh parents in
well-off communities are thinking about
hiring a teacher and doing a pod in that
way
but what for younger kids direct
instruction like this may work
but you cannot be on a screen for more
than 45 minutes at any particular time
kids have to be off the screen they have
to be able to engage in
their own kind of learning and we have
to figure out
how we get kids together in some way
form or fashion
to stop the social isolation in terms of
older kids
i think you flip it you can actually do
direct instruction asynchronistically if
you want to you can
just like with you know college kids you
can
tape a lecture but then you really need
the group work to reinforce
or to create some alchemy and that's you
know but
but just like you have done so much work
so in in this
we have share my lesson we have
unprecedented numbers of people who have
joined share my lesson we make it for
free for
everyone for parents for kids for
teachers
um and so and and every day we put
tricks of the trade up
the other thing i think is you could do
things like
using tv um you know uh
fox in in in washington dc
um would have like an hour where it was
dedicated every morning to
um the you know to to a different lesson
by a different master teacher you saw
that in
um in california as well
in the spring i think that you know
lectures from the masters finding ways
to
have really interesting content is going
to also be
really important doing things in a way
where
families can come together i love the
fact that we had lin manuel at our
convention
i love that disney decided to put
that on um you know on air
around july 4th weekend using having a
family watch
hamilton and then you're doing some kind
of um
uh you know group instruction follow-up
and you could do it with a whole family
you make it a family enterprise as
opposed to
kids being isolated or you can do what
you know some people some families have
done this summer which is
they have a pod in the backyard or you
could do it in the middle of a
you know with in a housing project in
the middle of the
lawn in the middle of the housing
project so we we need to really kind of
think about different ways of getting
together
having that engagement using the screen
for certain things
and reinforcement for other things on
dependent upon pedagogically where kids
are
that that makes a ton of sense and and
rhymes or in some ways is exactly what i
think when we've been trying to advocate
uh very very similar things you know you
can have asynchronous learning
obviously tools like khan academy
there's other tools out there where
kids can get practice feedback teachers
can monitor but then the necessity
of having some form of whole group
synchronous
community building i loved your ideas
especially if you could figure out ways
you could do it in person
somehow at a park and smaller groups uh
but at least have some time
but what i was hearing is you know 45
you don't want a stretch of more than 45
minutes on a screen
it's just bad for the eyes and the brain
i think that's true for adults as well
but and but obviously just you know make
sure there's breaks in there but kids
feel like they're part of a community
what is there some baseline
recommendation you know i've seen
uh you know in the spring we saw
versions we're just like here's a couple
of links to some
virtual schools that are doing
everything asynchronously
which doesn't seem like a great
experience based on what you just
described
you know all the way to i've seen some
schools that have been doing everything
you just described
what's kind of a you know a minimum
viable experience
in your mind that at least parents and
and and teachers should strive for
um so you know at the end of the last
year
we thought we we were very big believers
in capstone projects done
um in a developmentally appropriate way
i mean you're not going to have a
fourth grader write a phd project on
you know lincoln and the gettysburg
address and
you know why did that not actually you
know eliminate
eradicate racism in america that's not
going to be what a fourth grader does
but it could be what a 12th grader does
an 11th grader does
and we've seen in terms of portfolio
schools
how they were actually very adept at
being able to move
to remote because of the kind of
guidance they had done in terms of
critical thinking and group work and
things like that
so at the end of last year we thought
capping off
capping off what people had done kids
had done during the year was really
important as
and and we call the capstone projects in
terms of the beginning of the year
i would actually say as a bottom line
well-being and community building and
that the children will be okay
is going to be most important um
pam cantor um that uh who's
who who leads turn around schools or
turn around for children
said something to us at a town hall we
did with the pta
in march or april and she said
uh mind a calm mind
will be a learning mind we have to
make sure we reach kids
and we create confidence and calmness
that they'll be okay and that means that
the well-being
issues become really important and the
engagement issues become
very important as a pathway to
getting to instruction i want to double
underline that last part
and people might even be surprised
hearing it from me because obviously
khan academy is very much focused on
you know do have you learned this math
or this science or this humanity
standard
uh but i couldn't agree with you more on
what you just said that you know so many
people right now are so focused on oh
what if my kids don't learn to factor
polynomial on time
well yeah that is an issue but if their
mental health
if their friendships if their
connectedness if their confidence
somehow atrophies or dies through this
process then we have a much
bigger problem and what do you what how
do you address that if we have to be
distanced if
if we can't figure out the logistics of
meeting in a park is it you know you
need at least
30 minutes on zoom together with your
friends and
and teachers what is that minimum
situation look like there's another
question
you know from youtube susana garcia
dominguez do you think students have to
have the same number of hours in online
learning you know is it nearly six
hours what is that no i don't i don't
know
some of this i think that some of this
we're gonna learn
we're we're trying to create this box
like okay we have to figure out 180 days
okay we have to figure out
x number of hours okay if we don't do
this what is going to happen
we're in the middle of a pandemic
can we actually if we could try so so
yes
i know you know i'm basically saying the
rules have to be rewritten
the rules have to be rewritten right now
the pandemic isn't over
when it's over we can actually figure
out what we need to do
moving forward but just like you said
if we don't actually create confidence
and engagement for kids if kids are
socially isolated what why are the
pediatricians
including my sister who is an intensive
care pediatrician at montefiore hospital
why are they constantly saying the kids
look at the kids look at the social
isolation look at the
the fact that kids who are not on
digital look at kids that need grab and
go's
maslow comes before bloom any day of the
week
and we have to make sure that we meet
kids primal
needs that's art that has to be our job
and and if we do and we create
confidence we're going to get
to the other instructional pieces and so
that's why you know i know all these
states
are saying what do we do with all our
rules i'm
focused on how do we help start
school in a meaningful way for kids and
for their teachers
who are some ways their lifeline to
the next to their dreams so
is there a minimum you know i don't know
what the minimum we're
we're just we have a lot of prac we have
a lot of practices now
i don't think we can say we know what's
best yet because they haven't been
tested
what we do know is that you know just
like
with adults if kids end up having
like a zoom dinner with their friends
just like you know my friends and i we
have you know sometimes we'll have a
zoomed drink
you know or before or in the midst of
the new york
shutdown so we'd have a zoom drink
together you know we'd have zoom dinner
together
we'd get together in that kind of way
not more than 45 minutes or an hour
because
of the same reasons but i do think we
have to find a way to get kids
together and that the and that creating
these kind of pods that families are
doing creating ways
of getting kids together in a
you know socially appropriate way
wearing masks
being physically distant is very very
important
and if we can do that in terms of
schooling if we can use
even a school building even if we're
doing remote
and we have like a saturday afternoon
walk with our kids
that's you know that will be important
but that's gonna we're gonna learn
more and more but the point is it's
important for people to get together
and to see each other and to be in
community with each other
no couldn't agree more and the time has
gone by way faster than i expected i
i could i could talk to you for another
several hours there's so much i want to
learn from from you on one kind of last
question maybe to sum up everything and
i learned
look i've been learning from teachers or
and educator
and and paraprofessionals and bus
drivers
and um guidance counselors we've
basically
really taken in all the learning from
people
all throughout the last several months
in terms of what has worked and what
hasn't
no absolutely and i mean based on that
based on all of these data points you've
seen
if we're talking a year from now i'd
love to know kind of both your hopes and
fears you know the fears
what are what's kind of some of the
there's going to this is clearly
sub-optimal situation
on so many dimensions what's some of the
the things that we're going to have to
repair
a year from now and are there some
silver linings are
there some things that we might a year
from now come out uh
better for so you know
i'm an optimist so i always have to
think about a silver lining
even in the midst of these three crises
um
look um so number one
we have to fight the pandemic
truth is very important science is very
important
and and those things we we need
leadership
that will fight the pandemic that's
number one
and i think frankly even though the
country is very polarized right now
more and more and more people see that
and that is really important
number two i think that out of this
will be a sense that public schooling is
really important and found
and and the community building and
people
kids being together in person is very
important
and and that and and it's not simply
the means of parents who who
now have a healthy respect
for that that teaching is both a science
and an art form
and a craft as well as a skill but that
the whole alchemy of having public
schools is important
and that remote can be a supplement but
it's not a substitute number three
i think that this gives a new kind of
um movement builder to
science and the importance of science
and the importance of
data and and and understanding
the world and understanding what science
means to the world
number four um i think
it gives a sense that we have to work on
things
equitably that in this pandemic
just like so much else um
the people who have gotten really really
hurt
um are the people who are most at risk
in normal situations and in in you know
and you see it in terms of
who's gotten the racial health
disparities
you see how racism is really built into
so many of our structures
in america and number five
i would say that working families
and working people are the ones who have
gotten us through where we've gotten
thus far
the grocery workers the nurses the
doctors
the emt folk the people who have been on
the front line
actually making sure that the rest of us
got fed
got helped the teachers who made sure
that kids were engaged last year or
trying to figure
out right now and so this has not been
you know as important as um uh
you know a president is supposed to be
um or uh you know or
you know a big media star is supposed to
be this has been
everyday people and governors in many
states
who have really gotten us through this
so
those are kind of silver linings that i
see i i think
if we can create a confidence that
dreams will not be
the you know dreams may be deferred for
a minute or two
but we can get the economy back after
the virus is tackled
i think if we you know if we get a sense
of confidence that we can fight the
virus
and confidence that america can pull
itself up
again like it did in the recession
the great depression then i think um
we will be able to meet the needs of our
kids
but if we don't fight the virus and if
we don't make sure people are safe
um then i am very fearful for the future
yeah well randy thank you so much i mean
this was an incredible conversation
um as i said i could keep going uh but
i you know i know in this in this time
to have any time with you is a real
honor and
i think you've really helped a lot of
the folks watching
understand all of the issues that play a
lot better so thank you so much
thank you thank you for everything
so thanks everyone for uh joining
today's conversation obviously we went
over my apologies to randy i probably
kept her
longer than um we originally promised
but uh
uh i think i thought there was just too
much uh to talk about frankly there's
there's more
that i would like to uh but but i i got
a couple of very powerful takeaways
there obviously and so you know safety
first we're in the middle of a pandemic
um what i heard is what i thought made a
lot of sense is
you know when you can create safe
environments and let's be creative about
creating safe environments with
ventilation
with uh maybe it's the younger kids
maybe it's not a full day whatever it
might be
you know you meet up in the park uh
those are reasonable options but when
community spread is very high
you we kind of have to hunker down as a
little bit of society and i also heard
on the instructional side
let's not try to do everything for
everyone that'll just create a lot of
stress and it's frankly an
unrealistic goal we're in the middle of
a pandemic try to focus on the basics
and the
the most basic of basics is kind of the
maslow's hierarchy people feeling
safe and secure and part of a community
and if they have that if their mental
well-being is good their social
well-being is good
then we can start to build up on that
and once again we don't have to do
everything
but if we can get some of those core
skills of math reading and writing make
sure they don't atrophy make sure we
have some progression
that we're we're going to be holding the
fort uh reasonably well
uh when it comes when it comes to
education so thanks everyone for joining
uh and thanks for your great questions i
will see you i'm actually going uh
on a on a mini a much needed camping
trip tomorrow uh but so i will see you
next week
you